hello there it's time for issue three in
the fortnite and marvel crossover comic
book series the zero war this is the
series in which we break down the core
plot and highlight the important lore
elements and talking points about
fortnite i'll link the full series of
videos if you're joining us late my
creator code is adamaru and as always
throwing the video a like helps out a
lot anyway let's do this zero war issue
three
last month we left wolverine and co
fighting dinosaur beings in wakanda's
serpent valley as a second unit of
heroes traveled to the moon to locate
the mech and its pilot who crash-landed
there back in 2019 and that's where
we'll begin today foundation scientist
and iron man have found the paradigm
she's been here for years without food
or water but she's okay her armor kept
her body in stasis kinda like when
animals hibernate over harsh winters in
fact she's not the first member of the
seven to be trapped safely in their suit
the foundation once sat motionless at
the bottom of a river when he fell
through the zero point and into the dc
universe but i digress tony stark
attempts to introduce himself to the
paradigm but the foundation cuts him off
it doesn't matter wwe fans will know
that line was made famous by the rock in
his wrestling days and the rock plays
the foundation it doesn't matter how
you're doing it doesn't matter how you
feel it doesn't matter what your sign
says he believes the paradigm is a
traitor to the seven for helping the
imagined order build and pilot the mech
back in chapter one and talks about
executing her on the spot yikes standing
to her feet the paradigm states
everything he said is wrong and points
out the io plan to create a doomsday
machine to eliminate the devourer before
it could reach the zero point the
problem was that would annihilate
everyone on the island the imagined
order only care about the zero point so
the paradigm made a deal to escape her
prison she must pilot the mech saving
the zero point and saving every life of
every looper on the island and then she
escaped into space paradigm tells us her
homeworld makes her uniquely qualified
to pilot mex if you're wondering why
she's in the mech hot seat instantly the
scientist believes the paradigm and tony
stark seems to like her too so the
foundation is forced to yield on this
one the group look at the remains of the
mech and paradigm says powering this
thing up will take forever luckily we've
already got a plan and tony tells the
paradigm about the other group of heroes
searching for the crystallized piece of
the zero point right now
[Music]
over in reality 616 wolverine spider-man
jones the imagined and shuri are
battling dinosaurs and ninjas and
bonding with each other by demeaning
spider-man earth's stockiest hero
spider-man brings up his rule to never
kill and that heroes need to haul
themselves to a higher standard to which
wolverine continues slicing up ninjas i
never claim to be a hero eventually a
hybrid is caught and interrogations
begin the thing is nobody can speak
lizard man not even jones who officially
speaks
342 000 languages although he admits he
could probably figure out this language
in a week but we don't have that long
bro meanwhile wolverine is preparing
triceratops for dinner as night falls
the group camped for the night and a
conversation about life begins wolverine
opens up to the imagined stating he's
almost 200 years old and also he
instinctively knows the imagined is an
older being too we get more important o
law now as the imagined explains her and
her sister were genetically modified by
their own father before they were even
born and then the bombshell we've all
been waiting for her father is geno
wolverine is shooketh just look at that
face like most bad guys he doesn't know
he's the bad guy jenna simply wants to
create the perfect civilization the
ultimate imagined order which is also
what he names his kids which is a bit
weird if you ask me
the imagine tells us that geno is
immortal and so are all his children and
due to that long life his views on
perfection became an obsession
eventually he sent his kids into the
loop wiping their memories and giving
them 22 minutes to escape jenna bet that
his children are so perfect they would
be the first to ever escape the loop but
he was wrong they did escape but they
were not the first that title goes to
the renegade wader geno's attempt to
make the perfect offspring failed and he
replaced both the imagined and the order
one of the first times a snapshot was
created as we all know talking about how
terrible our parents are makes everyone
horny and the imagine takes the
opportunity to give wolverine open mouth
surgery with extra tongue we'll leave
them to it in another panel shuri stops
peter from walking in on wolverine and
the imagined that could have been really
awkward oh and if you're wondering
during all this time jones and shuri are
bonding through a conversation about the
omniverse
in the first issue where agent jones
visited his office to grab a photo well
we now know what was on it it's a
picture of his wife and kids and things
get a bit heavy now everyone in that
photograph is dead they're all gone
spider-man assumes they were killed by
the imagined order but joncy quickly
shoots down that theory the imagined
order protected them they died of old
age and here's another bombshell jones
is also immortal he slowly climbs the
ranks of io and became an indispensable
member of the imagined order when he
asked to leave to grow old with his
family he was coerced to stay with
threats against his homeworld in other
words if he stayed in the job his
grandkids his great-grandkids and all
descendants would be safe and protected
he was io for life it was only when the
imagined order began threatening all
realities that was jones's moment to
stand up and fight back so the scene
where he switches allegiances is far
more important than we know he's doing
it for his own homeworld and family too
we cut back to wolverine and the
imagined and they finished their sexy
time they chat about smashing geno's
face in oh and then they go back to more
sexy time let's leave them
the following day the hunt for the zero
shard continues and instantly a new
fight begins a stegon arrives the guy
spider-man name dropped last issue and a
new band of dino dudes arrive to fight
with him instantly this goes one step
higher as another dc super villain is
here this chap is the high evolutionary
he's claimed the zero point shard and
plans to use it for well you've guessed
it evolution his whole deal is finding
ways to take mankind and other earth
species to the next plane of existence
and just like geno that obsession went
too far and the high evolutionary began
creating his own planets like
counter-earth a place where he could
artificially accelerate the evolution of
all species but this is a different
timeline so let's see what happens and
his real name is herbert good old
herbert
before we arrived the high evolutionary
has already combined the zero point
shard with antarctic vibranium i admit i
had to do a little research on this one
it turns out antarctic vibranium is like
an anti-metal the opposite of standard
vibranium it vibrates causing any other
metallic touches to weaken and liquefy
and as shuri's weapons are vibranium if
they strike arctic vibranium it is said
that both metals will shatter instantly
hopefully we'll get to see that suddenly
driven by her hatred of perfected
genetics the imagined lungies at herbert
but this only acts to annoy him a battle
like no other kicks off and let's be
honest if someone showed you this in
2017 and said it was fortnite you'd
think they were insane during the battle
spider-man slips away and attempts to
stealth into the vault to grab the zero
point shot but plot twist someone beat
him to it it's dr doom he used the good
guys as a diversion and now has
possession of the zero point shard
contained with an arctic vibranium doom
portals away quickly leaving behind more
hybrid ninjas to fight and another plot
twist the battle outside ends a few
minutes later and both sides are
chatting to each other the high
evolutionary expected doctor doom to
steal the shard and knows that he's on
his way to reality zero doctor doom is
coming to the island the imagined asks
herbert to help them fight doom but he
declines his time with the zero point
has taught him a great deal about the
future of his world and he chooses to
stay behind to protect earth rather than
entering the multiverse his final words
are chilling he has seen the end of not
only our reality but all realities and
that's where we stand after three issues
of the zero war i'm adam thank you very
much for your time if you've stayed this
long here's a bunch of legends who used
my code it makes videos like this
possible i'll see you next time
[Music]